well I mean Marvel's not doing anything
with blade so Sony is exploring further
ideas into potential spin-offs and solo
movies for spider-man related characters
that they happen to have the rights to
because obviously we're already getting
venom that has started shooting they're
still developing black and silver for
black cat and silver sable and
definitely with venom probably with
those ones as well they're not gonna get
introduced in a spider-man movie first
they're just gonna start making these
movies but there's another one that
they're developing that is the first one
that I've kind of gone that could work
and that would be Morbius the living
vampire and this is a character I
actually know a bit about I've got some
Morbius comics from the 90s the
character has been around longer than
that history is actually kind of funny
I'll go over this real quick if the
moniker living vampire seems a little
weird to you he was created I think it
was in the 70s but basically at a time
where the comics code was still enforced
and it was such that they were not
supposed to write about undead horror
characters they weren't supposed to
write vampires where you know zombies
werewolves were off the table all that
stuff they were not supposed to write
about it so when they wanted to
introduce a vampire character what they
did was rather than have him be the
undead back to life sucking blood from
the living he instead was a scientist
who contracted a disease the symptoms of
which were coincidentally identical to
vampirism pale white skin can't go out
and son needs to drink blood but he
never died and came back so he was a
living vampire and therefore allowed
under comics code yeah it was kind of
dumb when the guys just functionally a
vampire although he did it did actually
play into a story a bit because he was
constantly looking for a cure which was
kind of his schtick for a while he kind
of became an antihero they kinda give
him the Punishers thing with it with
basically his idea going I had this for
hunger I need to feed if I must feed and
if I might
kill people by doing it I will feed off
of evil people and criminals so they
kind of it was like her cross between
blade and the Punisher a little bit um
and he kind of worked he was kind of
nifty he's had a couple different
designs his original he kind of had this
upturned bat nose the more recent
designs are a little bit sleeker I kind
of prefer them but it this is a
character who even though he originated
in the spider-man comic and has appeared
in spider-man related materials if you
watched the 90's spider-man cartoon he
was in that but he does actually not
require spider-man not only in terms of
his origin or anything else he doesn't
require his relationship to spider-man
isn't what makes him interesting in fact
at this point his connection to
spider-man is so tangental I was
slightly surprised to realize that Sony
even nabbed the rights for him when they
got spider-man
I mean again yes he was introduced in
spider-man but you know so was kingpin
technically but the rights for kingpin
still ended up ultimately being tied up
with the daredevil rights because he was
much more associated with that character
Morbius kind of is his own entity at
this point if he has stronger
associations that all sort of like with
the whole midnight sons thing and that
whole sort of dark occult corner of of
Marvel which is you know things like
blade and ghost ride or Johnny Blaze
when he wasn't you know embodying goes
right her stuff like that so I it was a
little bit surprising for me to realize
Sony caught the rights to this but you
know what it's a property that could
actually work as a solo movie and we
don't really have an active vampire
franchise right now I think the last one
that got any traction was Twilight
unfortunately but you know I think this
this is a road worth going down
unfortunately that enthusiasm is
severely tempered by the writers
currently assigned to this now it's a
writing duo they've written I it's four
or five movies let's see if I don't
remember these now they wrote the new
Power Rangers gods of Egypt
the last witch hunter and most relevant
to this Dracula untold the first failed
attempt at starting a universal monsters
universe so I I try not to come down on
writers too hard I know that most
writers unless they are also directors
or you know somehow have built a really
good name for themselves like you know
unless you're somebody like Aaron Sorkin
writers generally are writing on
assignment they they don't really get to
craft a story they get to you know
figure out the logistics the nuts and
bolts but by and large they're working
by dude they're working to match a
director's vision or off studio notes or
on assignment or what-have-you so I try
not to come down too hard on writers
except at this point this is for badly
written movies that these guys are
behind so that ya know I think I gotta
say they are not very good at this so if
you find yourself wondering how'd they
get the work well Hollywood is weird
that way and people especially for what
is considered to be a more technical
kind of profession like writing because
I mean they do can and again unless
you're dealing with a real artist of
screenwriting
terms you know your your Joss Whedon's
your David Mann that's your Sorkin's as
I mentioned then they really do just see
most you do see it as a technical
exercise so when they hire writers they
are not looking so much that was the
last film they wrote a well-written film
they are looking at do they deliver on
deadlines do they write to the budget
outline that we give them do they
integrate notes well and it's stuff like
that if the answer to those things and a
few others some of the things are yes
they will continue to get assignments
regardless of how good the scripts they
cranked out are so yeah that's
unfortunate I mean I it could be saved
by the right director a director with
vision who's willing to you'll come in
and say look let's reshape the story do
this and then these guys are just you
know working under the vision of a
director who's good because I none of
the other movies that they've been
involved
had very good directors so yeah and
again that that's not me saying that
they didn't write bad scripts in those
cases but I'm saying maybe those could
have been elevated by actually good
directors or directors who are still
good in the case of Alex Proyas but just
and and until there is some talent
assigned to this that I can look at a
track record and not cringe I can't
allow myself to get excited even though
the concept of this character getting
his own film I think would actually work
I just don't like the people they've
currently got on it but I'll be keeping
an eye on it and as far as like I said
as far as Sony's spin-off ideas go I
mean they've got the - they've got
moving forward and previously scrapped
stuff there was the sinister six movie
that we're talking about in a prequel
movie so like of all of those ideas the
ones that they both moved away from and
are actually doing this one actually
makes the most sense to me in terms of
doing a solo film so yeah I guess what
are your thoughts on this Morbius the
living vampire becoming a film do you
think it's a good I think it's a good
thing do you think it's a good idea do
you think that Sony's just gonna screw
it up even if it is a good idea whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that's available on Apple podcast I need
to stop calling it iTunes and stitcher
and I am also one half of the punch like
a girl podcast that is a presentation of
the fire and water podcast network Fire
and Water podcast comm and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]